it gets crazier people in California we
mentioned this the other day they
literally and I mean this literally they
literally want to pass legislation that
if you as a parent do not affirm the
gender identity of your child say your
seven-year-old who comes home and he's a
boy but he likes Barbie and he suddenly
says he's a girl they might let the
state take your child away yes this is
real here is California representative
Laurie Wilson pushing AB 957 which if
Republicans and the rest of us were
smart right when they called hb1557
don't say gay we should be calling ab957
Democrats or lunatics bill
that's another one that would be
possible but anyway listen to her in her
own words on what they want to do to
these kids
so this particular particular bill ads
the very important factor that affirming
a child's gender identity is in their
best interest which is what your
question is about why does it get why
does it actually say that in an
affirmative way and it really is because
if you have a seven-year-old who's who's
talking about having a potential to say
I being able to articulate that they
believe that they are not the same
gender as they are biologically then it
should be affirmed and through care it
should be determined and that's what we
did with our own child and that would
give the ability for a parent who wasn't
sure to affirm and get their child the
care that they need to make that so they
can begin to articulate that
determination but by saying and
rejecting it in wholesale then you're
essentially rejecting your child and
that is not in the best interest of a
child we should be affirming our
children in every possible way and
getting them whatever appropriate care
they need whether it's based on their
gender sure whether it's based on how
their studies are in school it doesn't
matter our children should be affirmed
and this is saying that you have to
include gender affirmation as a part of
it lady who the hell do you think you
are you think that if someone else's
seven-year-old child is a little
confused about their gender that somehow
the government should be allowed to come
in and take their child away from them
and then mutilate their genitals you are
an effing lunatic all of you people are
lunatics and if you are watching this
and you live in California and you have
small children you must leave and if you
do not
one day they're going to come knocking
on your door for one reason or another
they'll have already taken all your
money you'll have meth addicts out in
the in your front yard you the whole
freaking place will be on fire but maybe
you will wake up when they literally
take your child away from you they never
stop and they are not going to stop
there that line it should be affirmed
she said just like my child so shocker
shocker her child is trans her child is
trans and now she wants everyone else's
child to be trans you know Jordan
Peterson talks about this a lot what
we're seeing really it's not a outbreak
of trans children it's an outbreak of
middle-aged basically mentally
compromised women like her they usually
happen to be white women she happens to
be black I don't really care about the
racial element of it but a bunch of sort
of spiritually devoid 30 let's say 25 to
you know child rearing age 45 year old
women who are want to be liked so badly
that they'll chop their kids genitals
off and then push that other people
should do it too it's absolutely insane
[Music]
foreign